six cents good unbreakable good signs
incredible to village good lady in the
water I like it happening you know what
I like it last airbender here we go
unlike most people I like Chevron's last
few films I don't love them like signs
of the village and unbreakable something
about lady in the water just gets me I
don't know what it is and the happening
I find that it's just like a fun little
Saturday night nothing to do curl up in
the blanket and watch it kind of move
any of my longtime viewers know anyone
who watched my interview with Tom
Channel - knows that the movie signs
directed by M night Shyamalan is the
movie that made me what I am today as a
movie goer it changed my entire
viewpoint of everything that movie means
so much to me so I've always followed a
nice shamans career very faithfully I've
liked basically every movie he's made
except for a wide awake which he made
before Sixth Sense and people are
constantly bashing him for you know lady
in the water for the twist of the
village and for happening and everyone's
always same kind of you know everyone's
always saying stuff about his movies and
I'm always defending him I'm always
saying you know what shemin's he's a
good director he's got it in so this
movie's called The Last Airbender it's
based off of the Avatar television show
that's on Nickelodeon cartoon it's about
a young boy who is supposedly basically
the coming Messiah of his time he is The
Last Airbender the person who is
destined to master all the elements and
to save a good-hearted people from the
Fire Nation
so will I continue to defend Shaolin
after this no I am so mad this movie is
terrible this movie is just bad I am so
sad to tell you that M night Shyamalan
has failed so horribly every single
scene every character is like in a
life-and-death conversation Shyamalan
had one tone throughout this whole movie
and it was overly dramatic
people are can be singing a tent eating
fish and they're like this fish is good
but we may die tonight I am so tired of
defending you Shyamalan I am sick of it
I cannot take it anymore from now on I
will recognize
is your earlier films as good but this
film is bad the acting is back the
special effects they're all right
they're fine I will give you that the
conversion to 3d stung the crap out of
my eyes my eyes were watering when I was
crying I was going like this and it was
look like I was crying cuz the movie was
sad or something it was sad I'm very mad
you know what this is basically a rant I
am very upset about The Last Airbender I
hope you enjoyed this review because I
am so mad about this movie this is where
the worst movies I've seen so far this
year I wanted it to be good and it's
piece-of-crap normal I'm trying to be a
little more serious now I was truly sad
the movie was coming to a close and I
was sitting there like why why Shaolin
why can't you make a good movie why
people want to see in this movie you
know people are actually excited for you
there was a whole bunch of people there
who really wanted to see this movie it
was like it was like the good old days
of Shyamalan glory where you were good
and you failed I read the book the man
who heard voices it's a biography about
M night Shyamalan and the making of
Lading the water and how everyone hated
the village and how it kind of made
Shyamalan crack a little bit I don't
know if he realizes that he needs to
stop writing the guy is an excellent
director this is however his worst
directed movie there is not one thing
that is memorable about this movie dev
patel from Slumdog Millionaire he did
okay the main actor Noah whatever ringer
I guess he is like a black belt karate
his action was good however his acting
was just you know fake everyone is just
that this elevated level of drama
however the movie around it and the
script just doesn't meet that level and
someone there like we're gonna die and
um I can't believe you're back and
you're the only one who can sing us it's
like I'm not feeling any of this
Shannon's pacing and direction of the
scenes is completely off there's a scene
in the movie where there's a close-up
shot of the main characters face and it
is so close up that his eyelashes are
top of the frame and his bottom lip is
the bottom of the frame it is like as
close as you can get to a person's face
it's that close and he is giving this
speech and it fails it doesn't work at
all now I was just saying they're like
oh no please please please tell me the
rest of the movie is gonna be like this
do you remember Joe's 29 minute delivery
from spider-man 2 he plays one of the
biggest villains in the entire film
every single time he came on screen and
tried to be intimidating I was thinking
vodka Joe was 29 minute delivery is a
promise I really wanted to just say sham
lon I'm with you I'm defending you but
you know what I'm just sick of taking
crap for you because you weren't helping
me at all
I wonder your biggest fans and you're
just not helping me action scenes are
okay some of them are actually good but
the best parts are all in the trim in
the show the main character's name was
Aang in the movie they call him hyung
for whatever reason they changed that
name Appa the big flying thing that's
awesome in the show is like just
completely uninteresting whatsoever and
he looks stupid
basically this movie seems like and
night Shyamalan was trying to gain some
sort of an audience back and so he
picked some source material that was
already successful decided to adapt it
he made it all special-effects he made
the trails over here with some big
gigantic epic and then when 3d got
popular he posed converted it into 3d so
he can make more money and it really
just seems like he's trying to make a
name for himself again by something that
his heart really isn't in I really don't
know if he was truly feeling this
project I just want him to go back to
making cool little suspense movies with
creatures and stuff but he should make
like a werewolf movie or something I
don't know
unfortunately this is one of the worst
movies of the year and night Shyamalan
what he needs to do is it needs to like
take a script that is already good that
he didn't write and make it into a movie
that is awesome and I'm airbending right
now I don't know why because he
understands direction not in this movie
though this movie it was like he took a
vacation I don't know what in the world
happened here he needs to take someone
else's script and make it into a movie
that's what I'd like to see however I
doubt he will ever do that because it
just seems like he's so intent on his
own
Tyrael even though it stinks right now
I'm very disappointed to tell you the
last airbender is one of the worst
movies of the year I give it one and a
half out of four stars do not see this
movie if you are a die-hard Shyamalan
fan don't see even more because you will
feel terrible this is a poster of The
Last Airbender this is a lighter and
this is lighter fluid I'm a member of
the Fire Nation
you